un paso en la lucha contra la
desigualdad en el reparto de vacunas
seis países africanos van a recibir la
tecnología de arn mensajero necesaria
para producir dosis contra el hobbit 19
se tratan de egipto kenia nigeria
senegal túnez y sudáfrica desde donde se
gestionará el centro mundial desde el
mar se trata de una tecnología de aire
nm diseñada en áfrica liderada por
áfrica y propiedad de áfrica con el
apoyo del equipo europa áfrica el
acuerdo forma parte de un proyecto de
transferencia de tecnología de vacunas
lanzado por la o ms el año pasado para
ayudar a los países de ingresos bajos y
medios a producir sus propias vacunas
más del 80% de la población africana aún
no ha recibido ni una sola dosis sólo el
1% de las administradas se han producido
en el continente el objetivo es que esa
cifra aumente hasta el 60 por ciento en
2040 dado que la producción de vacunas
se concentra en unos pocos países de
altos ingresos áfrica ha dependido en
gran medida del pro kóvacs y de las
donaciones desigualdad que el presidente
sudafricano cyril ramaphosa ha criticado
repetidamente
norte de áfrica es consistente y no es
aceptable que áfrica se encuentre
sistemáticamente a la cola en relación
con el acceso a los medicamentos aunque
apreciamos las donaciones nunca son una
forma sostenible ni un mecanismo para
aumentar la resistencia
de la unión africana había presionado
para que se renunciara temporalmente a
la propiedad intelectual pero europa
sede de varios grandes productores de
vacunas se ha opuesto a la medida
proteger la propiedad intelectual es
necesario porque es muy importante para
que sigamos creando e innovando y
tenemos que respetar eso la ms dijo que
empezará a formar al personal de los
seis primeros países en marzo para que
puedan empezar a producir vacunas contra
el virus lo antes posible